Another episode of Loki has arrived, bringing
with it some twists, a long-awaited cameo,
and even some unexpected romance. What does
it all mean? Where will our favorite God of
Mischief be heading next? Here's the
ending of Loki episode 4 explained.
The immediate question coming
out of Episode 3 was how Loki
and Sylvie were going to escape death in
the face of an apocalypse on Lamentis.
That kind of life or death situation brings
out some real honesty in both of the two Gods
of Mischief. Faced with the possibility of
being crushed to death, the two grow closer
and Sylvie opens up about why she's trying
to dismantle the Time Variance Authority.
As it turns out, Ravonna Renslayer is the
Hunter who originally snatched Sylvie from
Asgard when she was just a young girl, which
we see at the beginning of the episode.
The trauma of being ripped away from her home
has given Sylvie the goal of destroying the TVA.
In any case, Sylvie definitely has
a bone to pick with Ravonna herself,
blaming the TVA chief for forcing her to grow
up through "the ends of a thousand worlds."
As Loki and Sylvie await their
doom, the two Variants have a brief,
tender moment in the face of Armageddon, with
Sylvie affectionately touching Loki's arm.
However, when two Variants interact like
that, it creates a new timeline branch,
which alerts Mobius and the rest of the TVA
to their location so they can retrieve them.
One of the most surprising moments of the
episode was a delightful cameo from Lady Sif,
who hasn't appeared in the MCU since "Thor: The
Dark World," unless you count a 2015 episode of
"Marvel's Agents of SHIELD." Although her
role in the episode is only a minor one,
it forces Loki to take a closer look
at himself. Mobius traps Loki in a time
loop where Sif repeatedly beats him up in
Asgard for cutting off her hair as a joke.
Sure, the physical beating is torturous,
but it's not the true purpose of the loop.
Rather, it's what she says to the trickster
that slowly chips away at Loki's resolve:
"I hope you know you deserve to
be alone and you always will be."
The God of Mischief has always seen
himself as a loner and an outsider,
even though he was considered family by
the likes of Thor and Odin. Obviously,
this version of the character didn't get
the original story arc after the events of
"The Avengers" that made him realize that
he truly has a family. But this time loop
is clearly setting the Asgardian up to realize
that he doesn't want to live like that anymore.
Additionally, Loki is falling
for Sylvie - something Mobius
finds hilarious in his interrogation scene,
"What an incredible seismic
narcissist! You fell for yourself!"
Indeed, Loki's in love with himself, a development
that definitely doesn't seem like it will endwell.
However, Loki's conversation with Mobius
leads to the God of Mischief trying to convince
Mobius that everyone at the TVA are actually
variants whose memories have been erased.
Loki's insistence that Time Keepers
are kidnapping Variants and wiping
their memories to work for the TVA pushes
Mobius to look into his claims. In fact,
it says a lot about the impact Loki
has had on the TVA analyst that he's
started to take him seriously. Mobius and
Loki have struck up a genuine friendship,
even if that friendship is based on the two of
them trying to outsmart each other at every turn.
It's that friendship that makes Mobius sneak a
look at Ravonna's TemPad after she refuses to
explain what really happened to Hunter C-20,
which allows him to discover that Loki was
right about the TVA. This means Ravonna
is covering up the Time Keepers' deceit.
Obviously, Ravonna doesn't want this
information to become public knowledge,
so when Mobius starts wondering aloud about
what his life was like before being a cosmic
bureaucrat, she orders a hunter to prune him.
Hopefully, this isn't the last we see of Mobius.
Ever since the first episode of "Loki, fans have
suspected that the Time Keepers aren't even real,
largely because we haven't seen them in action at
all in the series so far. But in a surprise twist,
Ravonna takes the two Loki Variants to meet
the trio of "Space Lizards" - leading to
an interesting conversation between the
TVA chief and Sylvie. After everything,
Sylvie is still desperate for answers about why
her life was thrown into ruin because of the TVA.
The show still hasn't explained what
Nexus Event made the TVA go after Sylvie,
and Ravonna isn't about to open up about that just
yet. Instead, she brushes Sylvie's question off,
saying she doesn't remember why they were sent
after her, which visibly crushes and enragesSylvie.
After an atmospheric battle
in the Time Keeper's smokey chamber,
the series reveals the three aliens running
the TVA are actually androids... so clearly,
someone else entirely is pulling the TVA's
strings. But who's really behind the TVA?
Regardless, the Variants have proved that
perhaps a dash of chaos is exactly what
the Multiverse needs. They're even on the
cusp of confessing their feelings for one
another - a possibility seemingly ruined when
Ravonna prunes Loki right in front of Sylvie.
But wait - there's more! The series' first
mid-credits scene reveals that Loki might notbe dead.
Once again, the trickster cheats death in
the MCU, and the Asgardian wakes up in what looks
like a ruined version of New York asking if he's
in Hel. In response, a dramatic voice replies,
"Not yet. But you will be,
unless you come with us."
And that's when the show's biggest twist
yet is revealed, introducing us to four more
Loki variants. Is this new world filled with
other dead Lokis? Or is it home to countless
pruned Variants from across the multiverse?
Hopefully, Episode 5 will have more answers.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite MCU shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.